good morning John it's been over a year
since the last time I told you jokes
which means that it's time for me to try
to beat my record again this time 54
jokes in under 4 minutes
what's the difference between a cat in
the compound sentence one has claws at
the end of its paws one has a pause at
the end of its claws how about the
difference between a tuna and a piano
you can tune a piano but you could not
be on or Doudna the difference between
the moon and Julius Caesar the moon is
rocky and full of craters Julius Caesar
is dead why do you think was civil
disobedience such a fantastic essay laro
editing thorough what cell phones do
traveling nuns use virgin mobile and
algum her cell phone bill was so high
she was a Roman Catholic why did the
kicks ignorant the baseball team she
kept running away from the ball and the
mermaid that was weird what was she
wearing in math class oh yeah an algebra
why was the sand wet because the seaweed
see it wheat what happened when the
butcher backed up into his meat grinder
he got a little behind in his work my
pastor he ate too many beans here to sit
there and his own pews the defendant is
accused of bring dynamite into a steer
abominable I'm sorry we can't let the
elephant's back in the public pool they
keep driving their trunks what did the
policeman say when his tummy was
rumbling stop you're under a vest
subdomain Hector don't get puns they
always take things literally when the
attendant does two-photon if it had me
bag to check it said I'm traveling light
ah I had a really great boomerang joke
he'll come back to me so the Pillsbury
Dough Boy bounced off and I feel really
weird about donuts now what did this
subatomic duck say work the stormtrooper
was enjoying the Wookiee steak but it
was a little chewy I go so the cheese
move from the vegetarian Club but I'm
pretty sure I never seen her before
why are the Middle Ages sometimes called
the Dark Ages because they had so many
nights now where do you get whales Wade
at the whale weigh station named for men
that are in a rock group together but
none of them sing or play music Mount
Rushmore
they're a rock group it's a rock roof
date up on that but wanted to see where
the song went and then it dawned on me
the oddly Pleasant feeling of looking
down on a physicist as they drink the
last of their beer a strange charm of a
top down bottoms up how much does a
hipster weigh on Instagram the man goes
to a zoo and discovers that there's only
one animal and it's a dog it was a
shitzu
what do you go a snarky criminal
going down the stairs condescending
condescending what are the ten letters
of the pirate alphabet III are and the
seven seas PMS jokes are not funny Peary
so I was on a train with Einstein and he
turns to me and asks is Boston stopped
at this train a Buddhist monk goes to a
hotdog stand and say makes me one with
everything
Sherlock what are you doing with that
200-pound shrubs not a shrub it's a
lemon tree My dear Watson
how do you make holy water take regular
water and just boil the hell out of it
interesting story the guy who helped me
learn algebra never farted around anyone
I mean he didn't say it was a private
tutor my first girlfriend was a tennis
player but she broke my heart was like
love meant nothing to her ever since I
got punched in the nose by that clown
I've smelled funny and one of my first
videos I told you about a fungus and an
algae that took a lichen to each other
who got bad news their marriage is on
the rocks the Pentagon was actually
supposed to be an octagon but the
contractor kept cutting corners you hear
about that new indie band 999 megabytes
yeah that makes sense they don't even
have any gigs yet why did Barty Crouch
jr. quit drinking it was making him
Moody how did Abraham Lincoln bleed when
charged with murder he said he was
innocent he is innocent
they stopped the vulture from bringing
his rotting carcasses on the plane but
he said who's that I could have two
carry-on items a Roman walks into a bar
holds up two fingers and it says five
beers please what do you call a cow
that's just given birth decaffeinated
way called cat with no legs ground beef
would he call hell three legs lean beef
two legs yo mama some people believe
that becoming a vegetarian is just a
missed steak missed stick big once it's
a rare medium well-done
how do you fix it broken - but with the
tube of glue where does Doreen brush off
forever 21 or in grey jokes they never
get old
John I'll see you on Tuesday
you